Ron DeSantis had to deal with some
hecklers and he handled it very very
well Governor races president races
2010-12 16 18.
um
[Applause]
Jews against the samples
you gotta have a little Spice in the
speech right I mean you got to have a
little fun and then importantly here
DeSantis he doesn't Flinch he doesn't
move this crazy lady who claims to speak
to the Jews is escorted off stage the
ticket to get in just to do that I don't
know but Different Strokes so Santa's
makes a joke about it now I think that
woman can expect legal action from Ben
Shapiro I don't think Ben is going to be
thrilled with this woman claiming the
Jews hate Ron DeSantis I I uh I don't
think she really speaks for all of the
Jews